DEREK LIDOW: Creativity,
innovation, and design
teaches students
how to be creative
and how to apply that to solve
major real world problems.
University tends
to focus students
on convergent thinking, how to
come up with the best answer.
And so, students
don't get a chance
to practice divergent
thinking, coming up
with all sorts of
possible solutions.
That's what this class
is really good at.
MICHAEL IBERKLEID: As
soon as you walk in,
it's a room with a
bunch of possibilities
and a bunch of things
to play around with,
including your seating.
You can sit in a cushion,
you can sit on the floor,
in a metal chair.
So it's just like a place
where you can just come and do
whatever you want and
let your ideas flow.
YOLANDA YEH: Creativity
usually isn't
something you think
you can learn.
And so this class is
unique in that it gives you
the tools and the
opportunities to practice it.
DEREK LIDOW: The
final design project,
which is a wicked
design project,
is mitigating high-risk
drinking on campus,
which is an gnarly
problem that's
been around for
hundreds of years.
And students, when they come
up with really good solutions,
they will have
tremendous confidence
that they can solve any
of the real world problems
that they come up against.
TYLER HOPF: The final project,
solving binge drinking
on campus is the ultimate
first step to then after class.
Solving a real world problem,
or addressing it, at least,
and really doing what they can
to change someone's behavior.
So it's about designing
a policy, a campaign,
a series of products.
Really an entire project around
improving people's lives.
MICHAEL IBERKLEID: I think
the guests were actually
the best part the class.
Having people who worked for
gaming companies like Blizzard,
to the head of IDO, to
people who are very involved
in the university,
just gave us a lot
of different points of view in
terms of the different problems
we were addressing and how
to address those problems.
And really, it's those
things that you can't really
read from a book.
YOLANDA YEH: Essentially, what
we did was to build a website.
And the idea is that people
can anonymously share and read
the stories from their
community to better
learn about what the environment
here is actually like,
and to also be able to ask
questions and learn facts
in a very organic
way on the site.
MICHAEL IBERKLEID: Breaking
that mold of how to think
or what you're
actually learning.
First of all, I thought, how
can you learn to be creative?
But it's the
structure behind it.
That's what we really
learned and what
I feel like really I'll take
out of this class the most.
YOLANDA YEH: A lot
what I'm taking away
is being really
creatively conscious.
Thinking about applying
creativity to different places,
and also the specific
techniques we
use to develop empathy
for your users,
or to act on your feedback,
and just specific techniques
to jog your thinking,
brainstorming, and all that.